morbius is a marvel character who's been  an important part of the universe  he's brilliant i'm cure  it's finally possible he's strong  he's got some unique powers  but his powers seem to be out of his  control  what's happening  i love the opportunity to do something  transformational i've become something  different  it was a very intense physical role  more viasat is most frail and then most  monstrous  this superhero super villain  putting a new marvel character on screen  that had never been on screen before and  it'll be fun to see where we could go  without there's a web of opportunity  more bs exclusively in movie theaters  new trailer tomorrow  [Music]